hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey
so as i just said this is the road to
2000 and we've spent a lot of time going
over um like grand master games trying
to take ideas from grand master games
and emulate the grand masters
but tonight i wanted to mix it up i
wanted to to take you back in time to
when i myself was rated 2000 and i want
to go over some games that that i played
at that time against other 2000s players
a little bit better than me
um and i wanted to talk about how just
just how many mistakes can it can be
made in a 2000 level game of chess
uh
and the idea is by the ends you know you
won't even want to play like a 2000
anymore you'll want to be better uh so
hopefully we can learn some of the
mistakes that 2000's uh tend to make
and the main thing i want you guys to
take away from this is
a big problem a lot of people have is
that they tend to just instinctively
trust their opponent you know their
opponent plays some move you think to
yourself that's probably going to be an
okay move right you know you don't
expect them to just like make mistakes
especially if you're like a 1400 playing
a 2000 you're not going to expect him to
just like make some kind of big blunder
on every turn
um so the point is you got to stay aware
you gotta stay vigilant and you gotta
look out for uh for these kinds of
mistakes in your games
uh so to start with i wanna take a look
at a game of mine from the 2016
indianapolis open uh this is against
somebody named jason scott daniels
and while i was preparing for this
lecture i found out that i played this
guy a couple times
absolutely no memory of who this is and
don't remember his face don't remember
his name but uh apparently i played a
couple games of chess with them but
let's take a look so i start with d4
jason plays f5
uh so we're in the dutch i know that
it's a good idea to fianchetto and
develop the pieces in the dutch i'm a
2000 super strong so i then cuddle my
bishop i play c4 which is normal enough
my opponent goes g6 and bishop g7
so you guys know what line this is in
the dutch
um this is either the classical or the
the lennon it's the semi-leningrad it's
so it's in the same vein as the lenigrad
um
with uh with with this kind of
development so i play knight c3 and then
he plays this weird move c6
um
and so you know i obviously had no idea
what was going on at the time i was
rated 2 000. i barely knew the name of
the opening um i didn't know what i was
doing didn't know what my opponent was
doing i figured my opponent was probably
playing for something like this
but then c6 had been confused so i was
thinking you know what do i do i guess
i'll just develop my pieces and castle
the king so i play net f3 my opponent
plays d6 and i castle
okay so my opponent also castles
uh and then i want to get your thoughts
on what what should white be doing in
this position because i'm going to level
with you
i had no idea what's going on here i had
some idea that e4 is an idea sometimes
in the dutch against some lines but that
was the extent of my knowledge i didn't
know what else to do with my pieces i
didn't know where else to go
uh and so if you're playing a 2000 and
you get to move
what is it move it it moves seven in the
opening you know don't just trust them
to know what they're doing because odds
are they they're probably as clueless as
uh as the rest of us
so what's going on here you know i don't
know what i'm doing i'm only two
thousands i gotta find some kind of plan
so hello to everyone in the youtube chat
as always
gabriel harris great wolf tyranitar
everybody
so any ideas
intuitively i want to
push pawns in the queen side and
use our strong bishop to attack over
there yeah you're highlighting this guy
in g2 um and then many openings where
you think head of the the whole idea is
going to be to use this bishop open
things up
uh on the queen side of the board
um and that's honestly as good of an
idea as any uh the the problem you're
going to run into though
is if you start trying to just like push
kind of willy-nilly with something like
b4 right away
you're actually doing a lot to help your
opponent's bishop
as well so your opponent also has this
strong bishop on g7
kind of bearing down this this diagonal
so stuff like d4 might be might be an
idea
but definitely not not immediately
what else could white try and try and
play for here i always like trying to
trade
um yeah so you can try something like
that hello welcome welcome um yeah just
pull up a chair i'm sorry
um you could try for something like that
but it is actually going to be pretty
difficult to achieve like you know i i'm
not totally sure where you want to put
this bishop to be honest
um so gabriel harris in the chat does
have an idea they want to go rook e1 and
try and play for this movie e4 and that
was pretty much the only plan that i
could come up with in in the game
so
you know how do you approach a position
like this where you're not really sure
what's going on and you need to come up
with a plan so what you guys were saying
uh it makes you know some sense we
wanted to maybe activate this bishop we
wanted to maybe trade off uh black's
strong fiance bishop
but more importantly than that you just
want to figure out what your pieces are
doing so you see you've got your knights
here controlling the center bishop
helping to control the center and just
these pieces aren't doing much and so
when you don't know what you're doing
just try to improve all of your pieces
okay so
we thought about improving this bishop
but it's actually really hard you know
you have the general principle you want
to improve your pieces but then we look
at the specifics
i want to come to g5 but then maybe just
h6 and i think that these moves are
useful for black
you know just sort of expanding on on
the king's side and
don't think my bishop really got
improved bishop d2 doesn't feel like
much of an improvement over c1 and even
a square like e3 i'm walking into some
stuff like like knight g4 maybe
so this bishop hard to improve for right
now so what else can we just easily
improve trying to keep it simple
so
did we
shut down rookie one
yeah
rookie one is what i played in the game
and i think it's a perfectly fine move
uh if we look at what the theory is here
uh there's a lot of theory to go around
it's actually this move d5 that's the
best
and the reason why is it's a
preventative move it's trying to
keep this pawn at bay so that after e5
we can play d takes e6
and so this seems a little bit far
removed from what i was saying about
improving the pieces but the idea is
basically that if you you know don't do
this
um e5 still isn't playable right away
but something like queen c7 which is
actually played in the game
uh and then let's just say a pass
what white needs to look out for is
something like e4 coming on the board uh
shutting down our light squared bishop
so you guys weren't wrong in noticing
that um these two bishops were going to
be important in the position
um it's just that uh
you know you didn't quite see the
specifics of how they were going to be
relevant so the reason why e5 e4 is
black's plan is because it opens up this
bishop and it locks down our bishop on
on g2
so yes the position is kind of about
these pieces but when you look at the
specifics you can't just trade this guy
off the board you just can't develop
your bishop really
um and you can't just like launch pawns
down the board trying to go for this
because in the meantime black is doing
things like e5 and e4 and
you're gonna feel uh
you're gonna feel like you know what
what was all the what were all these
pawn pushes for if my bishops were
slacked down here anyways
so that's the reason why i think rookie
one is a good move now did i see any of
that as a 2000 level player in this game
no um i knew that e4 was kind of an idea
sometimes and so i played rookie one
trying to to prepare this move so black
plays queen to c7
uh and what do you think i should do
here after queen to c7
so we know black's plan i kind of just
showed black's plan but what is white
wanna
what does white want to do in response
and just so you know this is where i
start going horribly horribly wrong in
in the game so we can start laughing at
me pretty soon
okay so d5 is still going to be an idea
i just had no conception of this idea
being being in the position to to stop
e5 but yeah this is this is perfectly
fine um
maybe
i i would say it's it's one of the best
moves i think white can do a few
different things here that that are all
arguably the best but yeah this similar
idea is going to be fine here with
something like this going on
so d5 is still a good idea
but uh you know you're 2000 you've never
seen this idea in your life
no way are you coming up with d5
so what else can be done
what do you think oliver
bishop g5 so what did i say last time i
tried to play bishop g5 black can can do
something here that might be nice
do you remember
okay so i think still this move h6 is
gonna be good for black and again our
bishop is just gonna get
sort of pushed backwards and backwards
and backwards until
we've just given black a few free tempe
to expand again so bishop g5 is no good
all right so parker in the chat is
playing like a 2000 so i played bishop
f4 in the game you know i i um
i was like okay my opponent wants to
play e5 you know i'm a strong 2000. i
see what he wants to do so i'm going to
try to stop it i'm going to put my
bishop on f4
but this comes with some some pretty
obvious drawbacks so it's not
quite the same as when bishop g5
is how bishop g5 gets pushed back
but what's the problem with with bishop
f4
yeah what do you think
so knight h5 to start with
um but i actually did see this far in
the game and i thought i would be so so
clever and play queen b3 allowing the
trade of the knight for the bishop
but what was uh what was my mistake here
by the way i'm a very sneaky guy i'm i'm
trying to make a threat
very sneaky
yeah so i missed something pretty simple
here i think
uh
i'm not sure what you mean there
are you taking backwards oh yes so if
takes my idea is that i'm going to take
back with the g pawn and i thought that
i i could maybe just just maybe maintain
control over this square but i missed
something very very simple in the game
um
and here i'll i'll give you this next
move just to start with my opponent
stepped out of the the discovered check
so i brought my rook to the d file
but uh now black has something very very
simple just to
kind of prove why bishop f4 is just a
bad move
yeah so
my whole point of playing bishop f4 was
that i saw that my opponent wanted to
play e5 and i thought one move ahead and
said i can stop e5 i'll put my bishop on
f4 and in fairness to me i you know i
thought a few moves more ahead i saw
that knight h5 can go out with queen b3
and i saw that i had a tactical little
trick here where if you play e5 i check
take this guy
and i take this guy so
that's
the level of a 2000 i'm gonna claim you
know i saw a trick i saw that i could
prevent e5 for a move or two and so you
know i i played the move but you know
obviously like chess chess just doesn't
really work like that and so after my
opponent
you know quite simply steps out of the
trick play rook d1 now there's just
nothing to stop e5 and at the end of the
day i've wasted uh two full tempe just
bishop f4 bishop back to c1
uh and so this is the the kind of thing
that 2000's just aren't gonna be gonna
be as good at as as you might expect you
know if you have your plan if you
understand your plan
um it's really difficult to to kind of
stop it i i mean for example i just
wasn't able to prevent it here and i
played a ton of bad moves trying to make
it so that it couldn't happen
um so in the game i took on e5 to start
with and then i dropped my bishop back
to c1
but of course black is is already just
better here
um so why is is black better what move
should be coming next
yeah i think simply just e4 um i think
even immediately e4 is is perfectly fine
um
maybe my opponent was was concerned
about allowing something like knight g5
so he started with bishop e6 but the
idea is simple the idea is is e4
and here already i think my opponent can
just play e4
and like what am i doing you know my my
position is making less and less sense
um
oh he's just developing his pieces he um
he
so he wanted to go bishop e6 because
after knight g5 he wants to have this
bishop on this diagonal
so i think what he was worried about if
he plays e4 first i come knight g5 he's
not totally sure if he wants to play h6
and this is stopping bishop e6 i think
that's that's the reasoning for playing
bishop v6
um then after knight d2 uh my opponent
all what my opponent does is perfectly
fine as well he just continues
developing first
um i step my queen out of the pin
he brings his rook to uh to the center
and then i play b3
so
now of course
my opponent should play very very simply
you just play e4
your knights are sort of swarming my
bishop's caught off your bishop's wide
open
and i you can just you can do anything
you're threatening stuff like f4 some
kind of pawn storm on the king's side um
and just sort of winning by by improving
your pieces bringing the knight this way
put the rooks on the d file
um position's just just kind of great
for for black
but my opponent doesn't do this instead
my opponent plays the move b5 so what do
you think about this move b5
um
what's going on here
it feels a little bit unnatural right
like uh wha why is black playing b5 and
you know not always but more often than
not when a move feels unnatural it's
it's normally just not not a very good
move now
uh the exception is when there's some
kind of weird like tactical idea but
there's just no tactical idea here my
phone is just playing b5
yeah it seems risky
but just easily
take like
c takes v5
c takes v5 and then like
yeah so i mean it's gonna be double
edged here both of the queens are
are undefended but uh the main point i
want to hit here
is compared to e4 e4 locks down my
bishop opens up your bishop now b5
opens up my bishop and and does nothing
to help your bishop right so it's it's
sort of just missing like
the the relevant points in the position
um and i find that this happens a lot
looking back at my games when i was
2000. like
i'm sort of sort of just blindly
stumbling forward going from like one
trick to the next you know trying to
spot the trick that my opponent has
trying to have a trick that my
opponent's not gonna see
and and that's just kind of what chess
was for a long time
um so b5 you know my opponent has a
trick my opponent's trick is that he
wants me to take and he wants to like
play with this pin on on my queen wants
me to play bishop b2 or something and um
i'm gonna lose a piece because my my
queen is undefended
so you know i've spotted my opponent's
trick there you go that's all you have
to do to be a 2000 is spot all the
tricks um and now to beat a 2000 you
have to uh you know come up with
something better so we spotted the trick
we know what my opponent wants
now we just need to figure out what what
do i want in this position
what do i wants
so the chat has some some good ideas
but no one has actually suggested the
move that i played in the game which i
think is the best move
my
yeah so e4 is always going to be a very
important um aspect of the position so
it's not like white especially wants to
play the move e4 it does seem kind of
weird to to lock in the bishop like this
but the point is that it's at least
preventing e4 from black um meaning this
this dark squared bishop isn't going to
be you know cutting across the board
anymore
um the downside to e4 is that it is
going to get rather complicated here so
stuff like f4
is always going to be something you have
to think about and then you know some
kind of attack on the king's side
and black can also leave these pawns in
tension kind of forever play something
like knight c5 try to ratchet up the
tension on this square a little bit and
white's not really going to be thrilled
with any e takes f5 at least not
immediately with you know stuff like
this kind of
hanging in the air so e4 very
double-edged move um but uh it is in
general an important idea here because
we do want to stop e5 e4 from black
but there's a very nice move we can just
throw in
it improves our pieces it
shakes
shakes up the black pieces a little bit
very simple improving moves
yeah just go bishop a3 you know the
bishop we were struggling for so long to
find a good square for it and our
opponent kind of just gives us a free
move right we don't fall for his trick
and since we didn't fall for the trick
now we could we get just a free move to
improve our pieces so bishop a3 really
great move um
rook f2e8 now
and in the game i i do now just play
this movie e4
um and it's a little bit better in this
position than before bishop a3 because
we got the rook off of the f-file
um and we're stopping ideas like knight
c5
just because our bishop is a good piece
um so f4 is what the opponent chooses to
go for
and now i just play something like
knight e2 well i do play knight e2 but
something like 92 is good even knight f3
any number of moves here are perfectly
fine for white uh what you don't want to
do is you don't want to take here and
just invite uh invite all all kinds of
stuff into your position so just 92 in
the game it's perfectly fine
um queen to a5 attacks my bishop
and i just play a simple move bishop b2
um bishop d6 is a little bit better but
i i don't think that this i mean this is
a mistake i would make like even now you
know just
i want to keep my pieces safe um this
bishop attacks this pawn looks like a
good square
so g5 in the game by my opponent and now
once again i am just going to show a
complete
uh lack of understanding uh of the the
position so what i played in the game is
h3 because
you know i'm a two thousand i i think
one one thing at a time i i see my
opponent play g5 i say what does my
opponent want to do my opponent wants to
play g4
um
darn i can't stop g4 i guess i'll play
h3 and try to stop g4 anyways
but uh that's
this kind of trust in my my opponent
that i'm talking about you know why do i
care about g5 g4 why don't i care more
about about my own plans
so h3 is actually actively harmful to my
position it allows black to to play g4
and play things like f takes g and g4
with just even more
even more power because it's going to be
opening up more more files now
uh so instead
what do you think i should do i can be
proactive here instead of reactive
some very proactive ideas
um
so we know what the opponent's doing
opponent's trying to go g4
um and probably trying to play you know
that that introduces some threats like
f3 introduces some other threats where
he's just trying to take over over here
so we know what's sort of coming on the
king's side
so where else can we play
okay i'm not so sure what the chat is
actually talking about now
okay the chat's refuting themselves
uh okay so trent says he doesn't want to
give up his a2 pawn for free i just want
to highlight uh you can't actually
capture this pawn there there is a nice
idea here
queen gets trapped if you take on a2
okay so knight f3 is still the wrong
direction because black is playing g4
anyways
e5 is defended twice so you didn't have
a tactical threat and then i think
you're actually just losing a piece like
knight f3 g4 f3
all your stuff is attacked
so we see the opponent's threat coming
and we do something
multi-purpose advancing our own ideas
and helping to nullify blacks
okay danny says something funny he says
it looks like white's pieces are in the
optimal positions which i definitely
don't agree with
definitely don't agree with that
yeah so something like knight to c3 i
think is is really good so knight to c3
isn't a bad move at all
because it's number one anticipating g4
uh what do you mean by that because
after g4
f3 was a threat to to fork our pieces so
it's good to get our knight out of that
threat and it also is advancing our play
over here on the queen side and in the
center all right we know our opponent's
playing on the king's side and so we
want to be proactive on the queen side
and in the center so knight c3 is a good
move
to kind of do all of that you know we're
introducing ideas of taking on b5 thanks
to our opponent for giving us all of
those ideas by playing b5 unprovoked
for example if you imagine this pawn on
b7 it's going to be a lot harder for
white to make any progress over here but
now all of a sudden all sorts of ideas
to open things up thanks to our opponent
and it's also going to bring in ideas of
something like knight to d5 as as well
after we were to take on on b5 or
something
it turns out that i think knight to c1
is actually a little bit of a better way
to go about it but it's the exact same
idea we are drawing our night away
from the pressure over here on the
king's side
and we're rerouting it to help us over
here in the center and on the clean side
so something like knight c1 to d3 just
increasing the pressure on e5 and
getting ready to do something with these
queen side pawns
for example we're not worried about f3
just played the bishop back to f1 and
you know what what is black's
big scary threat here he pushed all the
pawns all of our squares are defended
um and white should just be pretty
significantly better i think in a
position like this
i'll just show you what might happen i
mean let's it's hard to play uh
do too much that's productive for black
you can't actually play queen c7
maybe something like queen to b6
but i can already think about doing
things like c5 as well
and something like b4 and just start
invading over here on on the queen side
now that things are so locked down on
the king's side by the way not totally
locked down on the queen side something
like a4 a takes b
and all of a sudden all the players over
here on the queen side where white has
more space
um
and of course since we have more space
we're going to be stronger on this side
of the board
so that's what i should have done that's
what i should have done that would have
been the sort of higher level chest
thinking
yes i see my opponent's idea no i don't
need to just react to it instinctively
um you know i'm capable of thinking
further ahead coming up with my own plan
and that's what a move like knight c3 or
knight c1
is gonna do for you instead you know i'm
2000 i'm afraid uh h3 just don't hurt me
please don't hurt me
um and then i think my opponent should
just play g4 right away
instead he takes on g3 i take back on g3
um and then my opponent gives me this
this check
okay so i'm in check and move out of the
way simple enough
and now g4 does come
of course now things are actually going
to be scary around my king because i let
black sort of open everything up here so
i play h4 trying to lock that down
and my opponent plays rook to f8
um so now
uh things look kind of bad right things
suddenly look very bad what happened to
these positions where i was
you know coming through on the queen
side those things are gone instead
things have opened up on the king's side
and i am staring down some major pieces
on on the f file
um so rook f8 uh turns out isn't
tactically the best idea though for
black because i can play this move rook
to f1
and then as 2000s do i had laid a very
very sneaky trick and finally my
opponent missed one of the tricks and he
plays the move rook to f2
so what was my trick
was my trick
white is suddenly winning out of nowhere
what do you think
brian just c5
and there's nothing to do here with
black the queen and the rook are being
interfered with
if you take
i can take
and because you've so nicely driven my
king to h2
rook takes f1 doesn't come with check
and black's just losing all of a sudden
black's just losing
um and that's how uh 2000s are gonna be
uh
pretty much anybody lower rated than
them you know they just keep playing and
playing and playing they keep not
hanging pieces they keep not making you
know massive blunders maybe they don't
understand what's going on in the
position but they keep setting these
traps playing these tricks and
eventually somebody's gonna fall for a
trick or a tactic and so
this is what you need to do to sort of
get better against playing playing
people at sort of the 2000 level you
just
stay vigilant stay aware of these tricks
and you keep playing your chess
uh now unfortunately for me the game
didn't end after c5
my opponent is able to sacrifice the
exchange here with rick takes g2 i take
back and then he does get a pawn for it
on c5
uh and so now the the real fun begins i
play the move knight to b1
not a bad move we trade off the rooks uh
h6
sort of a random move by black but it
gives this king a flight square i guess
um i bring my bishop back to c1 not a
bad move at all just trying to reroute
the bishop to e3 knight to b7 because my
opponent's not going to hang a tactic
like that
and then i just start playing sort of
random moves
which is often times what happens
uh when you don't know what you're doing
so i just played queen to c3
i honestly could not tell you what my
idea was i think i probably just wanted
bishop e3 somehow
but now my opponent plays c5
and for some reason i i give up on on
bishop to e3 i think that probably still
would have been a perfectly fine move
but instead i played queen to e3
my opponent just plays queen to c6
i develop my knight out to c3
and then all of a sudden knight to f6
comes on the board and you know i start
to realize
wait a second maybe i need to think
about the chess game again because uh
all of these threats are happening here
and black is is somehow getting counter
play so i play queen d3 one more sort of
nonsense move
and now all of a sudden black is winning
so kind of unexpected there but notice
what happened over the past five moves i
know i played through them rather
quickly but you know i'm just sort of
maneuvering maneuvering i move my queen
back and forth like four times
and in the meantime what does my
opponent do
my opponent plays one weird move h6
then after that he plays c5 gaining
space on the queen side
and then
he organizes all of his pieces to just
attack a weakness in my camp so
even though he's down in exchange for a
pawn uh even though he hung the tactic
uh he's already back in the game five
moves later and after queen to d3 he's
already just winning
so what's the winning idea now for black
any ideas
black to move is already
very very bad for whites
b4 is one idea but it's actually not not
the best
um
i don't immediately see why b4 isn't
good maybe it is pretty good but uh even
better for black here even better
even better yeah b4 maybe knight d5
actually i did have that one in my notes
okay the chat's getting a little
creative here with something like bishop
f5 but
you don't you don't need to be that
creative
um
don't need to be quite that creative
although bishop f5 is potentially also
also winning
i say that
tentatively
now bishop f5 maybe i move my king out
of the way and i've escaped the worst of
it
hmm
yeah so it's it's this move c4 that
causes all of the problems and um
i'm pretty much busted here uh i'm
pretty much just busted i played queen
to e3 in the game
but of course this just allows takes on
b3
takes on b3 and then my opponent could
have just captured my b-pawn
and then these pawns are way too strong
way too strong to uh to make up for an
exchange
uh for an exchange to make up for it
um but instead my opponent played uh
some nonsense move knight c5 and
no longer losing so
that's that's the back and forth that's
going to be happening in these games so
even if you do fall for the trick keep
in mind that the game's not going to be
over even against the 2000.
um so what would have happened if i took
on c4 first to not allow this uh take on
b3 kind of stuff well
i think my opponent could just capture
me back
and after queen to e3 um
well actually wait a second is is this
the idea
queen to e3 yeah and and b4 and now too
many things are hanging in the position
too many things are hanging
um you can go here
i guess
but maybe now this is simple enough
still get all the pawns still get the
past pawn over here
and yeah white's just in big trouble
king's way too weak
um but probably that was better than
queen e3 but in the game takes takes
knight c5 i'm back in the game
uh so once again i think uh my opponent
uh maybe missed this idea of bishop back
to a3 so for the second time around this
move comes to my rescue we get knight
takes on e4
take take and just king back to h2 and
the difference now is that i have
successfully kept my pawn on b3 and so i
i can still stay in the game without
those past pawns on the queen side
rolling down the board
my opponent plays a5 which makes a lot
of sense
i give a check because why wouldn't i
give a check
and i play bishop f8 and so this bishop
of fate move i think is probably a good
idea this bishop on g7 is doing a lot to
defend the king and i need some kind of
counter play against my opponent's king
if i'm going to survive this end game so
queen to c2 what's my opponent's idea
i take and then i see a trick so i play
it
the knight comes back to f6
rook to c3 queen to d1
check
and take and all of a sudden i'm back to
back to just winning
um so how did i end up being winning
here i think it was this move queen to
c2 that was the problem now queen to c2
was okay but after rook to c3 queen to
d1 was the mistake just just queen back
to f5 keep everything defended
and my opponent would would be okay
obviously it's going to be a very
complicated end game here but my
opponent would still be okay but instead
just queen to d1 is losing the e5 pawn
and now the king once again is gonna be
a little bit too weak
i play knight f4 which the computer says
is a big blunder but it was good enough
this is just complicated tactics now
we repeat and then my opponent goes uh
queen to f1 you okay oliver yeah all
right
we got water right behind you if you
want it
um
and then if my notation is correct which
i i think it is i repeated one too many
times in the position
and my opponent could have claimed to
draw
uh so look out for that if you're
playing a 2000 as well but my opponent
didn't claim the draw and i came up with
the best move which is queen to d4
and the point now is that i've stopped
my opponent's perpetual check threats
and uh i'm gonna be able to to actually
capture something over on this side of
the board
my opponent played b4 which was a little
bit too nonchalance
and now find the final winning move my
opponent has finally made the last
mistake
opponent has finally made the last
mistake
how do you win here
so we've got
all these pieces are all these squares
defended oliver you're making me nervous
buddy you got to sit down
don't play on the stairs
almost says rick to c6
um
maybe
i don't see why that wouldn't win um i
played something different though uh any
other ideas
net h5 okay repeats
don't do that too many more times or
else your opponent will claim a draw
maybe or maybe they won't if you're
lucky
yeah this is the idea of queen f1 though
is that it keeps this defended and
you're not so happy playing rook versus
bishop in two
what you got oliver
96 you mean
96 i mean he moves the king what's the
point
he blocks the check
all right somebody in the chat finally
has it oh what do you think brian i just
haven't bought it
all right well let me ask you this what
if i don't sacrifice my rook and then i
just take your bishop for free
taking the bishop for free seems pretty
good um i i don't see what's wrong with
with rook c6 either though it looks like
a very similar idea but yeah just queen
a7 and the bishop is attacked twice and
defended once and how do you defend it
again
you don't defend it again
and so then knight e4
check check mate and finally my opponent
has made the last mistake so
that is the the the craziness of a 2000
level chess game when when things get
complicated
so what what's the the take away from
this game well there's there's a few
takeaways
um first of all try not to fall into
this like reactive kind of play that uh
a lot of people are susceptible to my
myself included at at the time back in
2016.
um
and just realized that that these two
thousands you know maybe they're not all
like i was but it was very much just
like
okay fi find the tactic okay i i there's
a potential tactic now
darn my opponent saw it okay what's my
opponent's tactic uh okay i found my
opponent's tactic now i'm gonna react to
that like that's
that's what what playing chess at the
2000 level was was like for me and uh
the secret to getting to that level and
getting beyond that level is just being
aware of what's going on you know
understanding okay you know i'm staying
alert i'm looking out for any tricks my
opponent has any tactics that they're
thinking about and then moving one step
beyond that saying okay you know now
that i understand what they're doing
what is it that i want to do what am i
doing
not just setting traps but looking to
improve my pieces looking for good
positional ideas and looking for
long-term plans so that's um
that's the the takeaway from this game
at least
uh so questions on the specifics of this
game before i go back through some some
critical moments
no questions on anything
fair enough
oliver
you can walk up or down the stairs but
you can't you can't watch the class from
the stairs
my goodness oh my goodness okay let's
move on let's move on game number two
maggie fang versus caleb denby any uh us
championship fans
any us girls junior championship fans in
the room okay well maggie thang has
played one of those things um i don't
think she's ever been in the regular
women's championships but she has been
in the junior girls i think she probably
no longer qualifies due to being an
adult now
but at the time i was super excited to
play maggie fang she's very strong chess
player stronger than me at the time i
think still stronger than me now
um and i had black i was still a lowly
2000 at the indianapolis open and this
is how how the game went so knight f3 d5
g3 knight f6 bishop g2
e6 castles and bishop d6
so
notice anything wrong yet with this
picture
i've already done something wrong
oh okay yeah so i did hem in the light
squared bishop but that actually happens
a lot uh with with the black pieces
oftentimes you just don't have time to
get this guy outside the pawn chain
um what i actually did wrong is i put
this bishop on d6
okay
and it just shows that i already have no
idea what i'm doing it's it's move four
this time and i still don't know what
i'm doing so just never trust your 2000
opponents to understand what they're
doing so
this bishop just doesn't belong here uh
at all for a number of reasons number
one
my opponent fianchettoed their bishop
and by doing so they have really
strengthened this diagonal quite a bit i
mean the bishop just doesn't do a whole
lot here
um it's just it's e7 is just a better
square for for the bishop it gives it
more opportunities to come to this
diagonal if it needs to it defends uh
this diagonal from from any pins or
things like that
um and it's just it's just a better move
overall uh just a better square for the
bishop and outside of that we're gonna
see that my bishop's actually very
vulnerable on the d6 square you know the
bishops are long range pieces and you
saw especially in that first game when
we were talking about developing the the
other bishop out how if you develop your
bishop out too far too early often times
it's just going to get kicked around and
pushed backwards so bishop d6 just just
a horrible square for the bishop um d4
castles c4
i played b6 which is already kind of
weird queen c2 bishop b7 knight c3
knights b to d7
and because my opponent is not a bad
chess player and was above 2000 she
found a nice idea here so white has a
move that really highlights
everything that black has done wrong so
far
so white to move and get a a pretty big
advantage
um
yes so as we're running out of time
somebody oh brian
knight b5 the the the buzzer beater
um what was your follow-up that you said
if you move your bishop
well it's it's simpler than that it's a
free pawn
yeah so my opponent you know takes on d5
i i take back and then i'm like ah darn
because i'm only 2000 you know i say to
myself i fell for a trick um of course
that's not what happened here and that's
why 2200 2300s tend to beat 2000s it's
because they don't need to like you know
set a trick or anything it's that they
play good positional moves um and then
because they have a good position
there's a trick it's it's not like you
know they were
um setting tricks at the expense of
their position they were just improving
their position all of a sudden black put
the pieces on the wrong squares and so
white has a tactic um and that's how you
beat two thousands
um so i play knight e4 trying to stay in
the game but now just knight takes
bishop and
playing knight takes is is gonna be
really really sad for black
just because i think moves like bishop
f4 are actually going to be good now
just not having a dark square bishop is
is pretty abysmal for for black here so
i take back with the pawn to try and
introduce some intrigue
of course black is just going to be much
worse now
but it's okay you know i'm 2000. i don't
know any better i say how bad can it be
um we trade some pieces play b5
and bishop h3
my opponent has done pretty much
everything correct so far uh just
improving the pieces getting rid of my
knight on e4 and even developing this
bishop out now
but okay i play queen e7 the game keeps
going bishop f4
obviously this is just just awful for
for black already roxy7 trying to stay
in the game
queen a3 hits my pawn on d6
and because i'm 2000 at the time i say
ah you know i can set a trick here so i
try rook c6
e4
and i was like okay okay i i have my
trick this was my trick and so i tried
b4
uh which obviously
you know has no business working in this
position and definitely doesn't work in
this position
but my position was bad and i was ready
to 2000 so i didn't know any better
other than than to set a trick
uh so i tried b4 of course my opponent
takes it and my idea was to go rook b6
and try to get pressure against the the
b2 pawn
but does anybody see why this is just uh
immediately losing for like you know a
ton of different reasons
uh great wolf in the chat what you guys
are thinking great wolf in the chat asks
about other potential candidates besides
bishop d6 and why the others weren't
chosen
um this game happened a long time ago
great wolf so i don't know exactly
everything else i was thinking about but
uh bishop e7 is the the obvious other
candidate in the correct move just put
the bishop on on the correct diagonal
instead
um
sorry
uh somebody in the chat just says queen
back to a3 and okay i'm not gonna lie
white's a lot better after queen back to
a3 but uh queen to a5 is just tactically
sort of winning um
if you take on b2 as was the idea of my
trick um queen to c7 is
pretty pretty much game over here pretty
much game over the knight is attacked a
lot of times as is the d2 pawn as are
all your major pieces after uh e takes d
is gonna happen like
okay let's just play some moves like
something like this and okay like you
get the idea you get the idea
um
so queen to a5 would have just won
immediately uh instead my opponent
played queen to c3
i continue now with rick to c8 and i you
know i'm feeling good about myself i'm
getting all my activity
um and i take on e4 because otherwise
like i was pointing out d takes e is
just really really bad
so take back
and then i play rook to c6
and my opponent is is still doing very
well here of course i'm just down
down a full pawn and my opponent has two
very very strong bishops
but then they play this really really
weird move d5 and
uh all of a sudden after d5 i think that
the position starts to to get a lot more
interesting so why is d5 why am i so
critical of this move what do you guys
think
it gives up something really important
yeah was that uh that was that you brian
did you say that no no okay
who said e5 or
okay you're right i i thought brian
grandmaster brian smith i thought was
just like
um coming into my class and giving all
the right answers it's like unfair
uh but yeah no d5 gives up the the e5
square
and now white's still going to be better
here white still has an extra pawn um
but it gives black sort of something
something to hope for something to dream
about now i think the reason why she she
did this is because she was worried
about the pressure
um coming against this this pawn on e4
but there's a much much better way to
deal with this pressure um and it has to
go back uh it goes back kind of to uh
some chess principles there's a chess
principle here that makes a lot of sense
and that is when you have the bishop
pair you want to open things up uh so
how can white
open things up rather than shut things
down
and make some weak squares
yeah um
you said e5 right yeah e5 here i think
is probably the best move um and the
reason is rather than something like d5
which on you know
someday much later maybe i get a knight
on e5 i'm stunting your bishop and i
have pressure against a backwards pawn
instead of that this bishop stays open
this bishop gets even more open with the
d pawn
falling away
and
white is going to have a ton of pressure
here now obviously there are tactics
that you have to calculate with
stuff like rook to c2
but
you know all this stuff just isn't going
to be working out for
uh
for black here you know number one you
don't really even have a threat on g2
just yet
i'm just
you know i didn't didn't prep this line
but i do think i can just take on on the
square like d6 and like you know that
this is looking pretty nasty for for
black you know i move the queen but then
white moves the queen
and it's like checkmate stuff is
happening queen e7 this knight's hanging
tough
um so e5 would've been really good
instead d5 rook c5 um queen
uh d4 now i i play this move f6 because
you know i was 2000 and bad at chess and
i saw a square i was like i really want
the square
um f6 probably not the best move but you
know it's reasonable
it takes takes takes and i actually go
knight c5 here because i saw a trick
and then my opponent fell for the trick
so what was my trick
knight c5 and i had a trick
yes
because
that's the point of this lecture
basically is
um when i was a 2000s in 2016 and i i
still think 2000's today play like this
for my experience
um there's not a whole lot of chess
understanding there there's some chess
understanding but more often than not
the games are just evolving into you
know black plays a trick white plays a
trick black plays a trick white plays a
trick and whoever spots the most tricks
is is going to win the game and so i
wanted to kind of
you know expose myself as a 2000 and
expose all the other 2000s out there for
what they really are which is just dirty
tricksters that's all they do they just
play tricks every game
and uh
hopefully you know they see more tricks
than their opponent
is
yeah f5 is completely correct um of
course the trick
is what
yeah queen check and you just attack two
pieces at the same time even i could see
that
um so f5 and the pawns pins and now i
get my pawn back and all of a sudden you
know what why is black worse you know
i'm not so sure that he is maybe a
little bit because of the bishop pair
but
not not substantially by any means
now in the game we obviously continued
and after queen f7 i'm actually winning
this pawn so my opponent gave up on on
the bishop pair
and we got into this end game
which miraculously i somehow ended up
getting a winning position in which you
know i had no business doing
um i think this was a position where
uh black is just winning after bishop d4
um yeah i missed bishop b5 check which
is winning because of this line which we
don't really need to get into but yeah
queen e4 is is super nice
um swapping the queen and the bishop so
i can check with the bishop and cover g2
with the queen
um but yeah black is miraculously just
losing here um the idea is to go g5 and
white's just checkmated so white has to
give up the bishop
um but of course you know i didn't see
any of that because like it wasn't trick
that i i had i had planned and so since
i didn't plan a trick i assumed there
was no trick and i checked my opponent
around
had another winning position here for a
second but i missed all that too and
checked some more
and then here my opponent offered me a
draw and i accepted
um just to end the game in the funniest
way possible missed all the wins that i
had no business having and then uh we we
drew the game anyways
so again what's what's the point of the
lecture tonight well i wanted to show
you
um hopefully how much i i've changed as
a chess player since i was rated 2000s
and i wanted to show you just how
approachable it is to beat a 2000 at
chess you know they you know they're
they're not dummies they're going to see
all the tricks well not all the tricks
but they'll see a lot of the tricks and
they'll try to trick you but they're not
doing anything magical here it's all
very surface level stuff at least in the
games that i'm looking at
um
and you know i think
many many people are capable of playing
chess like this you just have to be
on your game you have to be really aware
of of the tricks and the position and
what your opponent's trying to do
and then to to get beyond that you have
to start thinking uh at a little bit of
a higher level start thinking about
long-term plans you know where do you
pieces actually want to be not where do
you have a trick and and so on and so
forth
so any questions for me before i wrap up
here and turn it on over to our grand
master in residence
okay uh well thank you all very much for
joining me do stay tuned for insane in
the end game with grandmaster brian
smith coming up right after this
um and as always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you guys next time
[Applause]
[Music]
you